wikileaks founder julian assange remains
in a british prison awaiting extradition
to the united states to face charges
over the publication of files that
detailed u.s war crimes numerous
journalists and human rights groups have
called for his release and mexico has
offered him asylum his biggest supporter
is his wife former lawyer stella assange
and in a rare interview she told dw
about her fears for her husband's life
and the impact his treatment is having
on press freedom worldwide
freedom for julian assange that's what
his supporters are demanding in front of
the british home office
stella assange is among them
appearing in public to talk about her
husband's plight takes a toll on her in
spain
but she says she won't stop until he's
free
julian's
life depends
on him winning this extradition
julian is clinically depressed if he is
extradited and placed in the type of
isolation that the u.s government says
that it reserves the right to place him
in then he will be driven to commit
suicide
stella assange fell in love with her
future husband while working as his
lawyer in the ecuadorian embassy in
london
assange took refuge there in an attempt
to avoid extradition to the us
leaving the embassy would mean being
arrested so for seven long years he
stayed within its walls
in that time they had two sons
their wedding took place in prison where
the family is allowed to see each other
for one hour a week
they check inside their mouths behind
their ears in their hair under their
feet they have to go through the dogs
that sniff them from head to toe and
they understand that this is a
place where they're not where
their father is not allowed to leave
stella assange wants her children to get
to know their father outside of prison
walls
ultimately once the
domestic remedies have been exhausted in
the uk
he can then appeal to the european court
of human rights
her husband is a journalist uncovering
war crimes not a spy
that's what stella assange keeps telling
the media
the u.s justice system however sees
things differently
they accuse him of inciting others to
hack into computer networks
it will define the scope of press
freedom in europe is it permissible for
a foreign power
to reach into the european
space and limit
what the press can publish think about
if china were to do exactly the same
thing and prosecute a journalist in
germany on the same principle because
that journalist exposed chinese crimes
european governments should defend
themselves against u.s interference she
says the effect is to chill the press
because
now
what can happen to julian can happen to
others
the fight to free her husband is
exhausting
but giving up is out of the question for
stella assange
until her husband is free